[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing fantastic beasts
3. i'm going to be releasing another
full length video
in a few hours in my more usual format
so stay tuned for that as well
with the recent resignation of fantastic
beasts star johnny depp warner brothers
are searching furiously for his
replacement
depp of course played the role of the
dark wizard girl at grindelwald a
charismatic sinister dark wizard
who tyrannized the wizarding world
before voldemort depp had already acted
in two films out of the five-part film
franchise
and this left fans asking who will
replace him
with regards to replacing him one man's
name has come up more than any other
maz mickelson ever since johnny publicly
announced that he would be leaving the
franchise
mad's name has been circulating and it
seems like he's the favorite for the
role
in fact a lot of the internet had
reported that mass was already
definitively chosen
however it turns out that this was all
just a rumor
when mouse was asked directly about the
role by ign he responded with the
following
oh that is on a rumour basis as we speak
so i know as much as you do from the
newspapers
so i'm waiting for that phone call so i
guess despite internet speculation
mads isn't a shoe-in for the role just
yet he said it himself
he hasn't gotten a phone call however
given the fan response to just the
prospect of man's taking over
and the way that his name has surged
across the internet warner brothers
would be foolish to ignore the
possibility
of him taking on the role that's it for
this video stay tuned for another video
dropping in less than 12 hours
until next time it does not tutorial on
dreams forget
to live